Curious how good your eyesight is?
Take a look at this image.
Who do you see?
If you're at a normal viewing distance from the screen and have decent eyesight...
...you should be seeing Albert Einstein.
However, if you're seeing Marilyn Monroe...
...you may wanna consider wearing glasses or contacts.
Wearing your glasses right now?
Try taking them off and the image may change.
Or if you're near somebody else, ask them what they see.
The effect can actually be seen by anyone...
...if we change the distance or size of the picture.
If it's far away, you're more likely to see Marilyn Monroe...
...as our eyes only pick up the broader strokes of an image from a distance.
But as you come closer to the image, you see the finer details of Einstein.
We promise, we haven't changed anything digitally.
In fact, pause this video now and try walking away from your computer screen.
Chances are, the image will change...
...and at a different distance than your friends...
...because our eyes are all slightly different.
The further away you can stand and still see Einstein...
...the better your eyes likely are.
You can achieve the same effect by squinting your eyes to blur the photo.